hey i'm jake johnson i'm here with
buzzfeed to talk about my firsts
what is the first thing that i do in the
morning
i make coffee i've gotten into a french
press that i have a whole system of
heating up the water that i've gotten
into i like getting into becoming
slightly
a coffee snob which is a new thing but i
like to start every day with the
coffee with the same process i like the
routine of it first impression of your
new girl co-stars
of zoe it was that she was a star she
was like a
tv star a movie star i was in the
presence of somebody who had already
done it
i was nervous around her and impressed
by her max
felt like a fully crafted
version of his comedy already he knew
what was funny about schmidt
and he knew what was funny about sitcoms
in a way that took me a couple years to
figure it out
lamorne felt like an old friend i saw
him on a commercial for like bud light
or something and when he auditioned i
really wanted him in
the show and he came to my house during
the auditions to rehearse together
because i felt like he was somebody i
grew up with i felt very familiar with
him
first impression of hannah simone was
that she was unsure of me and didn't
like me probably still the same way now
my first impression of damian wayne's
junior was
starlet just a true hollywood starlet
what is the first
job that i ever had i'm gonna go with
acting job i've had a million and one
day jobs but
they've all ended pretty uh painfully
boring
so the first acting job that i ever had
was i was in a commercial
where i played a ya a pop-up in a yahoo
ad
where it was just a photograph of me
wearing a wig
a guy's walking down and i pop up i had
a big mustache at the time and i used to
wear this big red
sweatshirt that was my ex-girlfriend
annie baker's father
sweatshirt and i wore his sweater in the
audition
they asked me to bring it for the photo
shoot and i was a pop-up ad i got in the
union i made a bunch of money and i was
really excited to be an actor
first thing you did after finishing the
screenplay of ride the eagle so we wrote
ride the eagle trent and i did
during the pandemic we would send it
back and forth a lot but we didn't
really finish writing it
until right before we started shooting
so i guess the
first thing i did after finishing
writing the script was start shooting it
my first
car i was living in iowa city iowa and i
bought
a 1981 chevy chevette i believe it was
called that was stick
shift for 150 and i drove it around
iowa city for about three months before
it died
but all the interior everything had been
ripped out of it so it was just like a
tin box
and it just had my seat and the shotgun
seat there was no back seat but i bought
it off another student
and you know it was a great first car
first person who believed in you
my older brother dan since i was very
young
would always tell me that i had what it
took to uh make it
as an actor and comedy and growing up
outside of chicago that seemed like a
really crazy dream but he
would always do jokes together and he
would always tell me that he would be
shocked
if i didn't end up on tv and so i really
believed him as he was my older brother
and i looked up to him so yeah shout out
to dan
first word that comes to mind when you
think of your co-star jk
simmons professional jk simmons showed
up
and crushed it he blew me and our whole
group
totally away we shot all his stuff in
about three hours
he came fully prepared he had made all
his choices and it was very clear to me
and everybody else
why jk simmons is jk simmons uh and it
was preparation
first time i realized that i was famous
i was at a museum in chicago
after new girl had started with my wife
we were walking around it was the
thanksgiving
of the first season and it just said
started aaron and i didn't realize that
many people were watching it and three
teenage girls followed me around
uh and were taking photos of me and
because i wasn't used to it i got
paranoid and i didn't know why these
young women were following me around
and i finally asked is there anything i
could help you with and they said
are you that guy from new girl and i
realized oh and then that christmas my
wife and i went to hawaii
and a car drove by of three locals and
one of the guys in the back
went who's that girl it's vic first role
you really wanted but didn't get
there was a lot of i auditioned for
years i didn't come close to anything
until new girl
i was flown out to new york and i
auditioned to play the bad guy in the
sitter with
jonah hill it ended up going to sam
rockwell which
probably a good choice super talented
guy but i auditioned
i was in the director's home i was in a
hotel waiting
and i found out the day that they flew
me home that uh sam rockwell got the job
but i was crushed because i believed i
got it
big first purchase i'm pretty frugal
with my money
i was always scared of losing it i
didn't start getting paid until i was
about 29 years old and i had a million
and one day jobs and i was always
checked
check so i kind of didn't make a big
purchase until
a few years into the show and then i
bought my first house first memory that
comes to mind when you think of nuke
girl
first memory that comes to mind is
prince doing that scene with prince
was an out-of-body experience i had been
a fan of his my whole life
and so sitting on a bench with prince
talking in between the scene the scene
where it's me him and zoe
all three of us just stayed in our seats
in between the setups we were probably
sitting there for over an hour together
and just small talking
i could never get past how weird it was
talking to prince and how
normal it was talking to prince first
ridiculously
untrue rumor you heard about yourself i
don't know if i've heard any rumors
about myself
oh there was a rumor that the cast of
new girl we didn't get along i remember
that that's
not true we're all still buds oh i know
the big okay here's the most
untrue rumor max greenfield every year
on my birthday says that i'm 50.
and a lot of people believe it and i'm
not 50. i wouldn't be mad if i were 50
but i'm not 50 years old but every year
he says that i'm 50 and then he goes on
talk shows
he did some like morning show like the
today show and he was talking to the
host about how proud he was that
i'm 50 and healthy and you know it's
ridiculous
so that one hey everybody check out my
movie ride the eagle it's a lot of fun
and i think you're gonna like
you